foreign
[Music]
I'm not getting one of the really good
preludes but these two are okay
one of the prelers actually had an earth
tag so I kind of had to take that one
so this is like a replay of a gamer
played a while back and I'm gonna try to
talk quick because I already cut this
down to one hour
so games games is going very quick I'm
already stressed so I the two preludes
there
pretty all right it gives me some extra
cards I wasn't that happy with my
starting hand so I kind of gambled and
took some extra card and definitely paid
off right that year I'm getting
sponsored also on Earth Tech very nice
business Network alternative Tech
and then I'm getting uh one of the
really good cards smart University I
really like that oh my God that's optic
Earth catapult as well is very good but
the marsh University is one of the cars
I really favor in these long uh
two-player games because it just uh you
can rotate so many cards and especially
with Point Luna it kind of adds up right
because alone Point Luna draws a lot of
car which means I'm gonna get a lot of
science text which mean I could get a
lot of value from us University
and interestingly I also kept happy
words in my starting hand I know this is
a card that can give me a lot of points
later on in the game but it is
yeah it is a little bit greedy to uh to
keep it this early on but I felt like
okay with away with it iron Manning
Industries obviously perfect at this
point Latino mine also great
I mean this is a high scoring game so
obviously I'm gonna have a love uh I'm
gonna be very lucky I already am happy
I get Earth catapult and I get a lot of
stuff
so this guy uh or girl I guess uh I I'm
very awkward when it comes to making
people on the internet like me so I I
don't know what to to respond to to a
person like this but
yeah so I remember there was Choice here
I could have gone for Io mining
Industries before playing Earth catapult
but I think I calculated and the Earth
catapult plus the one titanium
production would be just a slightly
better but there is a case to be made to
actually play Iron mining Industries
before you play Earth catapult because I
have catapult is also very expensive so
already we're in generation three
um I hope you guys can can still keep up
I feel like I had to cut this down
because in the end this replay is still
gonna be like one hour long which is
probably uh long enough in and of itself
so
but to give you some context this is a
game where both players both me and the
other guy had an hour to play which is
uh it was they desperately needed I
think because
um I'm ending up spending most of my
time and the thing is when you go for
this greedy cat strategy and I was not a
long time
so uh
but here this card basically is a two
make a great production and the
placement bonus but I can get a card
with it actually I get two cards because
it has an earth tag and then I I place
it
uh on the acronyms moons I guess which
also gives me a card so uh very nice
and then here I'm just uh playing
hackers pretty it's only generation
three so I think it's definitely worth
getting the two
and make a creative production
even though I I end up losing a point on
it then I top let me run the result
obviously also perfect I already like
played a lot of Earth attacks maybe I
think four or something
we can actually see now I go from three
to nine okay I played six Earth takes
yeah that's perfect
and now I think this generation uh I'm
probably looking to to play Iron Manning
Industries this card's in my hand for so
long and it's juicy I wanna I don't want
to play it
so Electro catapult also a great card
for engine building and we're still in
the early game so engine building is
definitely what I'm thinking about here
engine building and guards and then I
know that I have a great engine so I'm
also looking at oh here I do the math
right so 26 plus 12 it's 38 really want
to play Iron mining industry so I'm not
going to buy this car it's a
it's a lot of yeah look at this I'm
spending all my resources so this is the
reason I'm not buying this card
otherwise this card Rover construction
is actually fine
foreign
but
it's so fast
when I'm when I'm playing this game I
remember being stressed but when I'm
uncasting it afterwards after I actually
cropped down to one hour holy [\h__\h] this
is fast
there's gonna be a lot of actions in a
row especially later on so
I hope I hope you can keep up I have a
hard time doing it
obviously got like you can buy up to
forecast are we not playing crafting
I guess we're not playing drafting I
think I joined the game this time
normally I played drafting but this time
I think it joined the game
so uh
no
what what happened
oh okay I did buy them I just okay
I'm already confusing myself
but apparently I did buy three cards
here I just uh it I just cut the video
so it looked like I only bought one
which uh
I was just about to Flame myself but
this is actually fine
so this card here I think I'm at the
point
where I just want cards in my hand uh
because I know that I have a perfect
game here or at least a really good
start so I know that that at this point
I think I'll just keep most of the cards
I see just because I plan on playing
Marsh University and then I actually
need bad cards to cycle here so the card
I just bought is probably the one I'm
gonna cycle here
I'm guessing yeah let this piece of
trash
like it's uh it can be okay later but we
are nowhere near six percent and it's
not really an impactful part so it's a
perfect card to just throw away to get a
new card with Mars University
um so you know you're having a really
good game when you're actually just
buying cards just so you have bad bad
cards to cycle then you know you're
golden
so endangered workers I think it's still
early enough that I would prefer this
one if I had a lot of energy production
I would take the one to the right but
yeah
at this point I definitely know that the
five gold I get from indentured workers
is definitely worth it
um I actually uh um if you're wondering
what my opponent is doing uh it's it's
gonna be on the screen for just the
briefest moment sometimes I try to
include this but obviously mostly we're
here to see this this peak score and
this yeah cartel right cartel seems good
how much killed at seven and seven okay
it's pretty good I couldn't maybe
there's an argument to be made that I
should have played the technology
demonstration before I play cartel yeah
now I'm playing it it's not good
it's actually I should have played that
before because I could have top dig the
another arrest here right so a bit a bit
of a misplay right there
but when it comes to high scores and
Sarah from Mass I I I don't really care
about high scores and the funny thing is
I actually wrote in the in the terrified
Mouse Facebook group I just wrote well
does anybody even keep track of scores
it's a is it even a thing does anybody
have a spreadsheet and I think the
general consension concession nobody
gives a [\h__\h]
nobody really cares about how it's going
and I to be honest I don't really care
either right here I just keep bad cards
once again because I want the cycle and
been with Mars University
um so I I just thought that I would
still include this one because the score
is so high
um it's probably the highest score
you'll see
um
at least on YouTube the thing is this
Mass app only comes with Prelude and
vanilla so it's it's really hard to get
big scores normally if you play with
colonies and stuff it's a bit easier to
retrieve the really high scores
um
but the so I thought I should include
this because this episode is where we
look at like the greedy card strategy
and this is like this is a dream
scenario for the greedy car strategy so
you notice I already I have a huge
amount of cards I have 16 cards and I
have just a great engine and if you like
I talked about when you have both card
row and engine this is where you can can
really go inside
and every time you hit 200 plus in
terraform of mass it is with this greedy
card strategy at least that's the vast
majority you could technically do it
like with a series thread if you're
golden but like it's it's hard to
differentiate right because even in that
case you can make an argument that you
still have to have a lot of good cards
you still did the card strategy to some
extent when you're hitting these pixels
yeah definitely trying to make the big
scores are usually the card strategy
so medical lab is probably a card I'm
thinking about right now looks tasty I
haven't played my catapult yet I guess
uh I'm really lacking this uh energy
production
and the other available place I had was
were really good so but this is also
fine I can start right now we're hitting
the mid game so I'm fine beginning to
to get some plant production going
I think playing production is really
strong but I think you should do it
right here
in the mid game
especially because I have one of the
amplifiers in my hand I have the
nitrogen Rich asteroid I believe it's
called
yeah this one
so when I have this card obviously it's
also very good to to start playing
playing tags
I'm wondering if I have three right now
yeah so I'm buying probably the last one
as well search for Life yeah I'm buying
all four usually when I have this good
of a game I just buy all four so I have
something to cycle with it's
but this is like the the definition of
the card strategy you you you're being
really creative you're creating a huge
engine you're like keeping most of the
cards you see and somehow you end up
playing all of it and it's gonna be
resulting in like a lot of points
so I'm definitely also thinking about
the milestones at this point I see that
already uh the card Milestone has been
claimed I Believe by me it would make
sense I have so many cards
so I don't want to take them too early
like also talked about but right now at
this point this is about the time where
I really want to look at the milestones
yeah discarding flooding
makes sense
at this point my hand is so good that
like like a cat like Plantation I just I
have hope it was in my hand so I know
that this is gonna end up giving me a
lot of points
so mineral deposit and what am I doing
with this I could be just buying a
hmm
I'm actually playing this card
I guess I must have played decomposers
or something
hmm
yeah okay I see I played the other card
the card that makes a planned it's
actually cheaper okay that makes sense
because in this case I can just keep
collecting microbes on this card and it
will make my plan texts cheaper to play
so that makes a lot of sense
okay finally I'm getting some energy
production and I'm sure that I'm looking
at the Catapult because I really want to
get this out why on Earth
okay because I have plans of course
yeah so I can use the plans to power my
catapult yeah that makes sense I was
still thinking why am I spending all my
steel but I have a ton of plans so it's
not a problem
so I'm okay with terraforming the heat
I'm I'm predicting that it's probably
not gonna heat the heat that's like the
last Arrow parameter to close
so I'm probably aiming to to take a 14
generation game here because I know that
I have so much stuff going for me and an
ultra late game I'm just gonna
make a ton of points
okay Plantation I guess I needed the
last plant tag
otherwise it's not that good oh this is
interesting I actually like I don't have
a CD on the map yet so this Plantation
looks really ugly but I think at this
point we're still early enough in the
game that I have to play it right
because I need to play this nitrogenous
asteroid now I have seven plane
production definitely worth it but the
thing is I don't really just wanna play
a city for 25 just so I could get that
plus one point I mean it's at this point
the the VP is not the important part of
it so I think it makes sense to just
make this ugly Greenery in the middle of
nowhere
because
I needed the plant tag and it gives me a
little bit of resources right there
now I'm stealing his plan his energy
production
and medical labs probably on the cards
and yeah I played my catapult
so um
yeah we're vibing I don't even know okay
I go for supplement that makes sense
yeah
I have plenty of Mega credit production
and nobody's really building cities in
this game so getting rid of siblings
definitely makes sense yeah
this search for Life card I don't know
man it's ah even it's so cheap and it
has a science tag so this is why this
card is good but if it didn't have a
science tag and even after you have
played as I sometimes feel bad about
even going for the search for life
because
you pay one one Mega credit all the time
and and usually you're never getting it
like it's not a lot of micro cards in
this in this game especially vanilla
so it's ah
all right so I did get the plan I'm now
looking at the rest and the even though
I could claim one here I'm actually
gonna wait I'm gonna wait until my
opponent is close to claiming a
milestone
um because it's a little bit more
efficient this way
so now I have a fine opportunity to play
a city here I I did get all my engine
down so at this point I think it's an
okay time to start building cities
I need to have one sooner later right
because I have seven playing production
so preferably see I I could even have
drawn a card first to see if that was a
city card maybe that would have been
better but
to be honest this placement bonus of the
city was pretty good it was next to
water and then I can get this Greenery
down with one steel and four gold for
water so
it's a pretty nice place for a city so
maybe I just wanted to to get the
placement bonus as soon as possible
immigration shuttles
um
seems like an idea it's it's not a great
card at this point but it seems like
the best engine building car I really
have
um so I could still be considering this
the reason is not the best card is like
the five Mega credit production it's not
like
so great in generation 8 and nobody's
really building cities but
I think I figured I had a ton of
titanium so I probably still want to
want to buy it just for this reason and
also I'm thinking I have the dream games
the sooner or later I'm probably gonna
build a bunch of cities
yeah natural Preserve I just want this
uh
while I can because it has a maximum for
oxygen requirement heat drops heat
travels oh ketra okay this one
well
okay
I'm wondering why I wanted heat Travis
over this card
there's an argument to be made that when
you want a long game you can play heat
Travis just to to decrease enemy
heat production a little bit and this
way the game is going to be a little
longer but in this case the heat is
probably going to be the first parameter
to close so I don't know why I'm keeping
hit drivers but
I'm guessing that sooner or later I'm
probably gonna cycle heat travels as
well so it probably doesn't make a
difference
oh Advanced allies holy hell
I got Advanced eyelash yeah there we go
let's go
Advanced allies and I still haven't
spent my six titanium at this point very
nice
it's not great
um I think I I don't like this card but
I have decomposers in my hand and this
card can probably end up giving him one
point so it's okay in this case
oh man I hate Sally great so much
so uh
yeah herbivores
uh I need eight oxygens to get
herbivores
a bit awkward
I think it was mistaken earlier I said
that the plan tax would help me because
I have herbivores I think that's a
mistake herbivores is actually the card
where you get the VP when you put down
greeners you can have an animal or half
a point per animal
when you put down greeneries so
I'm wondering if I'm also going to get
ecological Zone in this game
hmm
yeah I'm just keeping everything like
it's it's not the cards are not the that
great but um I need cards to cycle
um so uh it's uh pretty amazing that
this guy hasn't claimed any Milestones
yet now he's even starting this
generation but
it seems like he's not the
he's not playing for any of them okay
um I'm now seeing that he has two
greeneries
and I'm like I'm also checking I'm
checking is it close to anything else
and he's not so
but he did have two Greenery put down so
he could make one more Greenery and take
a killer point so that's why I'm
I'm now claiming the gardener master
as intro
it's a little bit late but it's still
great ever break I'm only asteroid
get rid of it no to be fair leather
flows is not good at this point as well
I mean I could actually spend years
level flows to get the water
bonus so
I don't know I mean I think my reason is
probably I have so much titanium and
advanced allies so maybe maybe this is
one of the few games where I actually
play
error break them on the asteroid but
hard to say
yeah and you're gonna see like even
though the first Generations were so
fast
because I'm playing this super greedy
with all the cards I could get huge
engine super greedy card strategy like
the last few Generations is gonna be
insane as I'm gonna have so many actions
so
so we're far from over this whole replay
after I cropped it down is still one
hour or so
yeah okay now I'm finally playing it it
makes sense
I mean if I'm gonna play sooner later I
might as well do it now because it gives
me five Mega credit production it's not
it's not nothing it's just not as great
kind of the same thing it's like I kind
of want to play it because it has at
least three Mega credit production but
it doesn't really
it's not the greatest but I also play I
also want to play this card at some
point because I'm going for jovians
basically when you're having card game
like this you're kind of going through
everything I'm going for jovians I'm
going for serious energy I'm going for
playing production
I just want all of it because I can the
only strategy I'm not really using here
would be the terraforming strategy where
I will try to close the game I'm
actually going to do the opposite I'm
gonna try to
to to to
um well not really drag it out but I'm
not really uh
trying to terraform too much especially
the oxygen
I'm still gonna use my plans because I
don't think I have protected habitat but
uh
in any case if the game goes to 14 I'm
happy if it goes to 13 I'm happy at this
point I have no doubt in my mind that
I'm gonna win the game so
all right satellites
still a bit late but very good card
how many uh space tags do I have a
Wonder
I have seven yeah satellite is
definitely the way then so for for six
plus three for the card so for nine Mega
credits I can get seven at least seven
because I can even draw more cards right
and now I'm claiming the last Milestone
because he's close
oh actually he left at this point okay
yeah I'm just gonna
that's pretty much it the awards uh I
feel like there's probably
no Awards here that
that I need to start right now I'm
probably golden in like most of them
get the card there we go
so I did get the bonus even though I
sold the The Volcano card what's it
called lava flows so
it's all right
foreign
I really like this combo Olympus
conference
it's very late it will be like insane if
I had this card earlier in the game but
the the combo with Olympus conference
and Mars University this is actually
really strong I think it's just it's so
much value from science tax
and especially if you if you're like a
nerd like me and I played a lot of
terraforming masks it's a very valuable
to be able to cycle cards and be able to
to draw cards because you can get a lot
of value from them
so
um
Master University is just when it comes
to draw cards that's definitely one of
the best ones I think
sure you can have games where literally
get no science text and then it's it's
not good of course but
in most games especially in two-player
games Ma Olympus conference I mean it's
just insane
like just this card Trends Neptune Pro
now it's only two Mega credit and I can
and I can get so much value just because
it has a science tank right so
this card I just played basically is a
two Mega credit production so it doesn't
really do much but it was so cheap that
I might as well and also it has an earth
tag Earth takes also work on a wind with
my cooperation Point Luna so I am gonna
draw a card with when I play vintage
fifth text so it's good
I'm wondering if this game is like
progressing too fast I'm wondering if if
I should have
like just taking my time and make a
replay analysis that's like three hours
long but
I don't know nobody has time for that
right so
it's probably also the only replay worth
noting that's gonna be this long because
all the other replays I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna show too many of these God
game games like one one is probably
enough
so if if you're curious uh I fed uh
scores close to this one this is the
high score on the app in real life my
high score attire but once again who
cares it's so many different things when
it comes to high scores it's like
it's both if you're in the two-player
game you're gonna score higher if you
have more expansions available you're
gonna score higher if your opponent is
bad you're gonna score higher if the
game is dragging out so so you have to
make like a high score list that's like
10th Generation 11 12 13 14 and on top
of that you have to take into account
number of players and everything there's
so many different factors
so this is the reason why nobody cares
oh ecological Zone there we go yay
now I can get even more points for my
plant attacks very nice
right here what's on my mind is
definitely the the bonus
the temperature bonus on the oxygen
scale
I kind of want that
and then maybe starting with first award
is on my mind
um
this might be
I think my biggest mistake in this game
I make a few I may have missed but I
make a few mistakes one of the mistake
is not
starting all three Awards sooner
I think I was I was a little bit pressed
for time a little bit stressing because
I had so many actions I had to make
but the
and also I just I just assumed that I
would win all of them automatically I
just assumed that I would crush it my
opponent in every single uh award so
there was no need to actually start
anything
but if I'm not mistaking I believe this
is a game where he at some point started
minor which really annoyed me
because he ended up winning that
and it's not the end of the world
honestly it's it's not like I just
um but but the reason why it it was
actually important in this case is
because I believe I'm gonna pass
[Music]
um the last generation while I actually
have like maybe 30 gold or something 30
Mega credits I couldn't spend on
anything because the map was filled and
I don't have access to Vino scale and
stuff like this so so sometimes it
happens you just you literally have an
excess of money in the last generation
you can't spend
so when this is the case I should have
recognized that this guy was was could
compete with me in the miner and I
should have I should have just started
all three of them but the
it is what it is
and to be fair if I win three milestones
and two Awards out of three is probably
still fine right oh colonize the
training camp do I have do I have a card
so I can play this because I need like
uh one of the cards that can
enable me to play this card I wonder if
I've played that it has a science tag so
it would make sense that I played this
you know the science car that that make
it oh there we go adaption technology
yeah yeah yeah
so this is one of the few cases where
adaptive technology actually comes up
clutch like I think I already would play
this card because I have so many so much
science Synergy but normally this is not
a good card but in this particular case
it allows people to play column as a
training camp so of course it's pretty
nice
so it's a bit greedy I'm not taking the
bonus even though I could because I
wanted to to play my column as a
training camp first but now I should
never take the bonus right
that's what I have to do here
oh okay I see yeah
so okay I remember so uh I I kind of
want to take the bonus even now they
have them and I'm casting a like bonus
take the bonus take the bonus but
actually I I just I just uh
it's hard to say if I'm messed up
actually because I just cheated myself
from a point herbivores would have given
me plus one point if I played that
before these two obviously because I
have adaptive technology this is why I
could have played it now I think this is
what I missed that I could have played
uh herbivores before this because in my
mind herbivores is just eight oxygen
requirement but I just didn't
realize that I just played adaptive
technology so I could play before
but it actually ends up being okay I
think because what happens is that the I
think I have
and probably if I don't have it already
I'm gonna pick up the protected habitats
and then I'm gonna actually I believe
it's the case that I'm gonna wait a long
time before playing this card I hope it
was
which means that I now have a lot more
Mega credit to spend on
on a bit more engine and one of the
other nice things so even though I
missed one VP here I think it's like it
kind of evens out in the end because I'm
I'm just gonna be very greedy from now
on
and I'm gonna hold on to my plans
because I have protected habitat because
I want the game to drag out to go to 14
Generations
I have a I just have an unspoken rule
with myself that I I will never allow a
game to go to 15 Generations it's like a
it's a it's a bit too much it's uh it's
it's uh you should yeah it's hard to
explain it's just like if you do this
then you're deliberately just not
closing the game right
so unfortunate Generations you should be
able to to do everything you want to do
and again
and also worth noting at this point I've
I've noticed that my opponent
is not in the game anymore I think if if
my opponent were in the game I might not
have dragged the game out intentionally
maybe I don't know it's hard to say it
makes some might consider it to be in a
little bit of a bad Spirit to drag it
out just to get a big score even though
it's completely obvious that I'm winning
at this point but since I'm playing
against an AI because the guy left then
fine whatever
immigrant City isn't it time for this
because I want to yeah it is okay
yeah that's a good place for City
so
obviously my production is quite insane
it's not the it's not the biggest ever
but 45 Mega credit six titanium and
level plan obviously it's very good
um
so
the thing is that all of my cards I'm
gonna I only have 13 cars now and it's
it's gonna be pretty quick for me to
play my entire hand at this point
so I think this is why I'm I'm really
looking at the map now I think my plan
is to just fill out the entire map
and if you're getting close to 300 in in
like this uh
not close to 300 but if you're getting
like this like like
270 something score I've gotten a few
times
then obviously you just need to milk the
entire game for all the points to get a
score like this basically you need the
entire map you need a bunch of synergy
in your hands you need all the point
amplifiers
so in this case I don't think I got all
the Joven amplifiers but I don't even
think it's like about that what I am
getting for example is right here while
enhancer is going to give me a lot
oh am I stealing for myself no he has
lifestyle okay easy
I think it went for the fish because it
makes more sense to me that the bear is
fish
I can picture this in my head
sometimes it's very awkward for me when
I play in real life and there's a Venus
expansion and then there's like this
card venusian animals and then the bear
actually has to
to be on Mars be a bear and then he's
like putting on his spacesuit then he's
going to trip to Venus then he's taking
off his spacesuit and then he's actually
gonna eat a venusian animal
oh that was tasty and then he's gonna go
back in his spaceship and go back to
Mars again and this is very awkward to
me at I don't really I don't understand
how this is logic but that's how Mass
works
but in this case it's very very cool the
the bear eats a fish
I think this is very plausible
um so yeah I only have a card left so
our monitoring should have just closed
the game should we spend my plans just
well like that screw it let's have some
fun
definitely I kind of want to play at
this point because why am I even what
I think I think I really should play
this card right
because I want to play
oh here yeah mine you didn't see it you
actually behind in mine oh man
yeah but the rest of them I'm winning I
just assumed that I was gonna win all of
them so I didn't start anything it's
very greedy of me but the definitely be
a mistake
and then I made a few other mistakes in
this game I just can't I guess the
herbivore mistake was
You could argue with a mistake
I mean you could also argue it wasn't a
mistake because if my opponent had been
good maybe he'd taken the
the bonus instead of me and then
it's hard to say
but the biggest one the one I feel most
salty about is not winning all the
awards
seems good
definitely one series at this point
the two tells I'm looking at here I
think makes the most sense
um
it's like
you want when you're creating your
Empire you want this kind of pattern if
that makes sense this pattern where the
greeneries can
hit two of your cities and two of the uh
the next city you're making so
so you can put two greeneries behind
your two cities if that makes sense this
kind of pattern you see here this is
like the the maximum way to get points
if you have the entire map for yourself
that is but
[Music]
that's right
nah
okay so I think I'm done actually
picking up bad cards because I think I
have enough bad cards in my hand to
cycle with so
I'm I am no longer picking up that caps
just so I can cycle this is this is done
oh there we go
I have ants so I'm putting microbes on
ants but this is a game where I didn't
do that for a long time where I just put
it on decompose I think it is decomposer
23 yeah oh
yeah I missed like two points here or
something uh and not right now but early
in the game
I think I missed a couple of points
because I put extra microbes on
decomposers instead of amps in my head
they just both gave the same maybe I
didn't remember I had to answer
something
but the answers ants gives Point per two
microbes and decomposers gives points
per three microbes so definitely I
should have just
like pumped up my ends instead so uh
small mistake there
at least early in the game now I think I
noticed so from this point on I'm gonna
I'm gonna put it on the ends so
but yeah look at all this stuff I have
man this is what I mean it's not even
about the Joven amplifiers it's about
all of this green text energy
like insane
of course Jovian amplifiers are also
very nice in a game like this
um I think maybe I'm getting three out
of four or maybe only two out of four
I can't remember
but yeah look at this 36 plants in my
hand yeah I definitely I I don't
remember seeing myself uh actually play
but but I'm not keeping 36 plants in my
hand if I don't have a protected habitat
so okay this land came is kind of cool
no sometimes you can use land claim to
actually annoy the other guy and stuff
like this put it in the middle of the
Empire but this is actually if I do say
so myself a pretty clever Lane claim
because this makes it a hundred percent
sure that I'm gonna put a city there
right because normally if you put a clan
claim I'm like oh I want to put a CD
there then the other guy is just going
to put a CD right next to that end claim
but in this game case that's impossible
because there are no valid spots right
next to the Lane claim to put a city so
this means that I have a pretty good
shot of getting in the city
um so a very clever length and good job
on this
select the card to this card Black Pearl
letters I hate this car it's never good
but it does give water yeah straight
mine whatever I think strip mine makes
sense because I have 36 plants in my
hand so
why would I I'm probably gonna get the
points
I also have Greenhouse if I have so many
plants
it's a
and once again I I think I only do this
because my my opponent is like lift the
game and there's a heartier
I don't feel bad about about a grieving
a hard AI but not closing the game it's
okay
yeah let's get rid of it
[Music]
I remember it came like as a surprise to
me that I actually
had so much gold left at the end I
believe that goes to 14 Generations
so when that is the case
um I'm feeling very bad about not
starting all the awards
I might as well
I've done that
but I still have the thing is I have
seven production in my in the in the
minor right and you're I don't know I
just haven't checked my opponent but
apparently he ends up getting getting
even more than me in the minor so
very annoying
important nitrogen
this card is so insane when I have a
card game like this one I can get a lot
of discard discount so this card is very
good in the late game when I have a lot
of discount
and then I have ants and I have uh some
animals that gives one point I know that
of predator for example and also it has
an earth attack so it also draws make
out on the late game
so a large Convoy important nitrogen
great cards to have I'm just gonna I'm
gonna I don't even care if I get the
water on the
large Convoy it would be nice if I did
but it's not even the the point of this
card the point is to just get a bunch of
points
in the late game I could actually play
it now it's not bad I have seven
titanium
um but maybe I'm I'm afraid to actually
terraform because I want the game to go
to 14. not sure
so this is what I mean I could have
played herbivores before and it would
probably have been better but then if he
had taken the bonus I would have been
sad anyway
but at the same time not playing it like
three generations ago it's like 10 mega
credit I instead use on other things so
it's it's the one point I'm missing it's
almost worth it
if you know what I mean
hmm
I'm thinking about getting the plant
what did I just play
oh this one that makes sense yeah of
course in this case I take the plan
I think I'm just making a
a microbe on this card just so my Ants
has something to eat
which is kind of funny
robotic Workforce uh I I I
have I had this for a long time because
I wanted to play this with medical lab
right
okay I'm doing it now but shouldn't I've
done this some time ago oh maybe I just
picked it up
but yeah this is insane this is one of
the it's actually the combo in in
vanilla mask because I don't have access
to cards like europolis and stuff like
this so medical lab robotic Workforce
such a strong combo and vanilla it's
really really good
salt station makes sense I mean it makes
sense if I get more than six Mega credit
from my opponent so it actually depends
how many attacks he has
or if the game goes to 14 then it would
have been it would be 12.
Mega credit I get from my opponent if he
has six
yeah this also makes a lot of sense
so I'm looking a lot at a lot of these
cars I'm like oh man I wish I had those
sooner but you know you can't have
everything
oh no no this is this a bug
I should be able to play it with only
one right
I have advanced that last game
insects another card I wish I had sooner
would have been very good for me but at
the same time I think there is a point
just like heat at some point you can't
use it anymore there's also a point
where plants at some point you can't
actually use it anymore if the map gets
filled up it doesn't happen very often
but in a card game like this it's
entirely reasonable that it would happen
especially if I let it go to
to 14. I mean look at this I have 60
plans 20 plan production and 60 plans
and I haven't even played insect yet
yeah this this map is gonna
this is gonna get filled up actually my
priority right now to be honest should
be to get all the good City spots I
don't think
maybe I'm I'm relaxed a little bit about
it because I'm just playing against an
AI but but okay I'm doing it
yeah this is exactly what I need to do
right now I need to get as many of the
city placements as I can
that's definitely what I have to do at
this point I'm expecting to fill up the
map with cities in this generation
at least this is what I should do
yeah I am okay
one to the left I think yeah
probably better
maybe I'm thinking if my opponent does
this and stuff but
[Music]
yeah this makes sense
so now I have all the good okay the
extra screenshot of Jesus now I have all
the good uh placement bonuses but
there's still like two more cities I can
get
okay there we go herbivores it's it's a
time that I start spending all my plans
it seems
oh did he pass
no he didn't okay
I think I'm waiting for him to pass the
generation because when he passes the
generation I know that I can I'm I'm I
know I know that I wanted to close it at
14. so when he passes I'm gonna
terraform
like until there's like one spot left or
something if that makes sense so just it
just barely goes to 14 Generations
because then I have getting the maximum
out of the tour from raining as well
uh Power infrastructure could actually
give me a little bit in the last
generation yeah yeah I prefer pumping I
prefer pumping aquifer pumping
yes good job
those seals pepper hands yeah that's
probably not a lot of good cards left
but the
it's also the cards that I discard with
my trash suit for Life cards right so
there could be some good cards still
left in the reshuffle deck
I also don't know what my opponent has
discarded so
but the
yeah
it makes sense
start to terraform the water a little
bit because I I expect that
my opponent is not gonna
close the game I could actually play
large Convoy right now just to get the
last water placement bonus
but I must have a read that my opponent
is not gonna just make four greeneries
because if he did that I would be really
sad
so I must have a pretty good read that
my opponent is not going to close the
game
because if he could close the game at
this point it would be a bad idea to to
make all the
all the aquifier
all the water placements
okay ants ants and yes good
[Music]
but like this is what I mean this game
normally 45 minutes or even half an hour
that's that's enough to play a game of
terraforming us on the app but it's uh
when you're having a God game this is
why I I usually queue for one hour games
because when you're having a guard game
like this like 45 minutes is nothing
because there's just so many actions
it's not only my actions I have to wait
for the game to do all the animations
so
I think I am stressing a little bit
about the time it could be oh one more
fish for the bear nice
Bears happy
hmm
oh
but I mean
search for life I'm not gonna get it am
I I probably know
there's still one more CD I could get
but I'm running out of gold at this
point but then again I think has he
passed at this point
if he has then I could just pick up the
last City placement bonus at the start
of the Next Generation because I know
I'm gonna start the next Generation so
that could also be a thing I'm thinking
about
this makes a lot of sense
just get just get a little bit of extra
make a query why not
the heat is closed anyway
oh and now my opponent has started the
miner
I'm not happy about that
was too greedy
great escapement Consortium could be an
idea
just to contest him in the miner
but
so this one I okay yeah
normally this is like you should watch
this tile like as a Greenery so yeah I'm
I'm thinking about putting in here but
I'm like no no this is gonna be four
next to four cities of course it's
better
but um
it's it's it basically gives you VP I'm
talking about the uh
the Tyler just played what's it called
commercial District I think
so the kind of gives you VP just like a
Greenery does except that it also works
on enemy cities so normally you want to
place this tile next to a lot of enemy
cities but but in this case I could
place it next to
to three of my own cities and learning
City
so there's there's no place sits on the
map where I could put it next to 2 enemy
cities so I think this makes sense
[Music]
I still haven't played insects
is it is it the case okay now he's
passed I'm sure of it no he's not
are you pausing
did he pass yeah there we go now he's
passed and I'm like all right now we can
place two greeneries and let's go to 14
Generations
yeah yeah
and then what I think is gonna happen is
it's gonna be an absolute race right now
in the in the Next Generation it's gonna
be a race to just get as much stuff on
the on the map as possible
like
because I have I'm gonna have 67 plans
next generation
so that's like seven or eight eight or
nine
Greenery is right there and I'm gonna
have so much gold so I can place even
more
greenhouses Jesus Christ
so
what did I just play
I could just sell two cards and still
play M6 no actually I can just uh no I
can't I can't make a Greenery because
then the game closes but I can still I'm
selling two cards probably so I'm
getting it
but at this point I don't know
can I even place all these greeneries
not sure but uh
probably also for the memes 32 playing
production let's go
[Laughter]
that's a lot of plans
[Music]
technically CEO's favorite project I
could be picking up media archives or
something or no what's it called
the one that gives you three gold when
you play an event so
that's probably why I haven't played it
yet
media is something I can't remember
so yeah right now
I'm very sad about him starting Miner
I'm just checking I'm like oh [\h__\h] I I
can't get this
so Rover construction once again a bit
greedy
I think I should have recognized that
I'm gonna end the game with with too
much Mega credits like an excess of bank
credit I'm gonna end the game having
like 30 Mega credits so playing stuff
like Rover construction it's not even
good at this point
like the only the only thing I have to
do right now is to fill up the map as
soon as possible anything else is a
misplay
of course if uh this is a misplay why am
I doing this I have a line clip
I'm not seeing the writing on the wall
like it's it's it's desperately
important that I fill out the map before
my opponent does even though it gives me
greeneries greeners next to my city
doesn't matter the map is going to fill
up I have to just spend my 77 plans
bonus please
fill up the map
I'm starting the last two Awards because
I don't want to mess up again but even
this it's a mistake this is also a
mistake
getting getting cards like
it's it shouldn't be a priority right
now this can wait fill up the map
and also I only have eight minutes left
so I'm a little bit stressed about time
I think am I finally realizing it it's
uh it took me long enough I think
yeah I'm finally starting to spend it
probably didn't occur to me that
that the map is gonna be completely
filled up but
oh this bug man
when you play greeneries too fast
uh you can't do it
so now I have to skip a turn and now my
opponent is gonna start feeling up and
I'm gonna feel bad yeah I'm gonna feel
bad about this pocket
but to be fair uh I have maybe I looked
at my opponent at least I should but you
can also make make a have an idea of how
many greeneries your opponent is
actually gonna gonna place
but uh yeah looking this back
um
it's of course much easier to just point
out my mistakes after the fact when I'm
not like super stressed for time but the
of looking at this after the fact
especially with the knowledge that I'm
gonna end up wearing a lot of make a
credit over yeah it's
the start of this generation should have
been to just fill up the planet yes
I wasted a bunch of actions doing other
things it shouldn't be a priority this
is a priority
[Music]
but to be fair probably it didn't matter
like
my opponent sooner or later he would
have probably
taken the the few
placement bonuses he had available to
him anyway so and and yes
nice
okay so now I can relax a little bit
more now the
but it's a little bit sad right because
I have 32 plant production and nothing
to spend it with so you could argue that
the uh like even insects in the last
generation I think it was still of
course worth it because I have
decomposers and it look ecological Zone
and also it ends up saving me a lot of
Mega credits because I don't have to
actually spend my mega credits
on greeneries now that I played insects
I just had just enough plants to do it
with only plants and not make a credit
but
yeah
probably I should have taken the ghg
um the one that makes microbes into heat
but doesn't matter at this point I
cannot fill up tardigrades anyway
[Music]
fish get a fish nice
I don't know the picture of of a bear
eating a cow it's just a little bit too
brutal for me I think it it makes more
sense that he eats a fish
I could be wrong of course
physics complex another card I want oh
yeah of course this is why I haven't
played uh CEO's favorite project yet I
haven't played physics complex oh I see
yeah so definitely this is why so I was
wondering why I hadn't played Dave this
is why you you wait until the last
generation before you play cards that
only gives you Victory point because
they could increase in value somehow
so definitely the right call to not play
uh
CEO's favorite Project Lead because I
could
technically pick up what I just picked
up
the one that gives me
physics complex the one that gives me a
two points per
science resource so
so this is what I I want to combo with
the CEO's favorite project
playing animals here in the last round
is fine but this only gives me half an
animal but this is still gonna give me
one point because I have vile enhancers
um so this is definitely where my head
is at right now I'm just gonna
figure out what gives me Point normally
I would figure out how to spend my money
the best but right at this point I'm
realizing oh [\h__\h] I have too much money
there's a I've messed up
yeah this is like
let's go 11 predators
Mars is going to be a very very
dangerous place to be
yeah
there we go physics complex
this might not really annoys me
he's gonna have six plus seven how the
hell did he get so much what the
I'm not happy about that not happy at
all
but it is what it is and to be fair I
mean
we don't really care about high school
center from us I don't think
so
it's just me being a little bit annoyed
that I could have played better that's
probably what it is
selling my cards I like this play just
in case that we are equal then in in the
when the game is over if we are at the
same
VP then it's actually going to be the
goal that decides the game so just in
case
I'm being ironic of course that's that's
like no way [\h__\h] in hell I I use this
game so I don't know why I sell my cards
but yeah
but I think I'm gonna have like uh this
one maybe one more maybe three at the
most when I have these card games and
then I'm gonna the other games that I'm
gonna show you is gonna be uh when I go
for some different strategies
probably more fun to
to see some of that stuff as well so uh
yeah
uh thanks for watching and I hope this
was uh okay
even though it's a bit uh stressed
bye-bye